mehr personal im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus in minister seehofer
stellt sein konzept vor
der papst verschärft die regeln im
umgang mit sexuellem missbrauch sind
kinder betroffen soll nun die weltliche
justiz informiert werden
boeing stellt die produktion der 737 max
vorerst ein
die wiederzulassung des fliegers dauert
länger als erwartet
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten zusammen mit
kristin otto für den sport genau ich
habe fußball und ski alpin guten abend
der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten lübke
der anschlag auf die synagoge in halle
mit zwei toten
es sind nur die jüngsten fälle
zunehmende rechtsextremer gewalt in
deutschland
die will die bundesregierung nun
effektiver bekämpfen bundeskriminalamt
und verfassungsschutz bekommen dafür je
300 neue stellen
denn laut innenministerium hat die
gewaltbereitschaft in der rechtsextremen
szene zugenommen die zahl rechtsextremer
gewalttaten stieg im vergangenen jahr
auf 1088 insgesamt werden zwölf 1700
personen aus der rechten szene als
gewaltbereit eingeschätzt
britta spiekermann der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lücke
mutmaßlich mit einem rechtsextremen
motiv und der antisemitische anschlag in
halle gewalttaten die die politik
alarmiert haben
horst seehofer will jetzt härter
durchgreifen und genauer hinsehen bei
der gefahr von rechts das nach unserer
einschätzung mindestens 12.000 personen
in deutschland leben die potenziell im
rechten bereich gewaltbereit sind
das hätte früher politisch mit dieser
priorität
versehen werden müssen rechtsextremismus
müsse genauso bekämpft werden wie
islamistische terror dafür soll es 600
zusätzliche stellen geben für den
bundesverfassungsschutz und das
bundeskriminalamt die bedrohungslage sei
hoch gewalt tagen schaffen zunehmend ein
klima der angst auch dass es zu
reagieren gilt und schweren straftaten
natürliche angriff auf dr walter lück
wir das antrag von halle haben diese
einschätzung ja leider auch schlimmste
bestätigt doch die sicherheitsbehörden
selbst haben probleme mit rechtsextremen
es gibt zahlreiche verdachtsfälle
künftig soll eine zentrale stelle
rechtsradikale auch bei der polizei
aufspüren so könnten etwa rechte
kommentare in sozialen netzwerken
überprüft werden
das sind möglicherweise einzelfälle so
wurde das bisher betrachtet aber aus
meiner wahrnehmung zu viele einzelfälle
als dass man sie nicht doch noch mal in
ihrer gesamtheit betrachten muss und
schauen muss gibt es dann netzwerke
rechtsextreme tendenzen auch bei der
bundeswehr
es gibt erkenntnisse über 30 personen
mit wie es heißt fehlender
verfassungstreue der kampf gegen den
rechtsextremismus noch mehr zum thema
haben wir online zusammengestellt auf
heute de finden sie unter anderem eine
fakten box mit hintergründen zur rechten
szene und was sich künftig ändern soll
missbrauch ein hässliches wort für ein
hässliches vergehen für sexuelle gewalt
an jungen menschen die sich nicht wehren
können auch und gerade in der
katholischen kirche zahlreich geschehen
die opfer wurden mit ihren erlebnissen
allein gelassen die kirche mauerte
beschuldigte priester wurden in der
regel allenfalls versetzt
das soll sich ändern pabst franziskus
will den schweige code abschaffen
irgendwie zufall oder nicht der papst
ließ eine verfügung und einem besonderen
tag seinem geburtstag dem 83
das unterstreicht vielleicht dass der
kampf gegen missbrauch verhindern ganz
persönliches anliegen ist viele hatten
auf diesen allahs gewartet der papst
beendet damit offiziell das schweigen
der katholischen kirche das sogenannte
päpstliche geheimnis soll im
kirchenrecht nicht länger für
missbrauchsfälle gelten heisst nach
langem zögern ist die kirche bereit ihre
akten und archive zu öffnen
der papst hat sich gegen massive
widerstände durchsetzen müssen sowohl
den verschiedenen teilen der welt kirche
als auch direkt in der römischen
zentrale der römischen kurie da gibt es
nach wie vor viele vertreter die sagen
vorsicht langsam wir dürfen hier nicht
zu eng auch mit staatlichen behörden
zusammenarbeiten aber für den papst ist
es klar
ähnlich wie für die deutschen bischöfe
wir müssen hier transparent arbeiten und
müssen auch mit den staatlichen behörden
zusammenarbeiten
allein in deutschland zählte die
katholische kirche zwischen unserer 46
und 2014 mehr als 3000 opfer sexueller
gewalt kinder und jugendliche
missbraucht von kirchenvertretern meist
priestern die fälle oft vertuscht und
verheimlicht die kirche sollte keinen
schaden nehmen
mit dem erlass heute rücken die opfer
ins zentrum lange hatten ihre vertreter
dafür gekämpft
es ist ein wichtiger schritt der den
opfern auch signalisiert dass die kirche
bereit ist sie anzuerkennen und ihre
geschichte anzuerkennen und auch ihr
recht auf aufarbeitung anzuerkennen aber
jetzt müssen wir natürlich sehen wie das
umgesetzt wird der papst der kirche mehr
transparenz verordnet auf diesen tag im
advent haben viele opfer lange gewartet
ganz andere probleme in frankreich dort
spitzt sich der konflikt um die
rentenreform zu es wird wieder gestreikt
und das vor weihnachten wo städte züge
und straßen sowie so voller sind als
sonst und die proteste werden immer
massiver
denn jetzt hat sich auch die größte
gewerkschaft gegen die pläne der
regierung gestellt dass die franzosen
länger arbeiten sollen
christel haas über einen inzwischen
hitzigen konflikt
es ist ein alptraum jeden morgen jeden
abend und das seit zwei wochen
ansturm auf die wenigen metros busse
oder züge die überhaupt fahren betroffen
vor allem die pendler aus den vororten
george lopez hat es rechtzeitig zu
seiner schicht in diesem bistro
geschafft aber er ist erschöpft der
streik geht die oft die nerven
die regierung und die gewerkschaften
sind wie kleine kinder sie schieben sich
gegenseitig die schuld zu und das auf
kosten der leute die arbeiten müssen
streik- und dazu heute wieder
hunderttausende in ganz frankreich auf
der straße protest gegen die
rentenreform die das eintrittsalter
faktisch von 62 auf 64 anheben soll als
lehrerin werde ich fünf jahre länger
arbeiten müssen und trotzdem eine
geringere rente haben präsident makro
als könig ludwig der sechzehnte der 1
geköpft wurde
der druck auf ihn steigt mittlerweile
haben sich alle gewerkschaften den
protesten angeschlossen
manche drohen mit streik auch über
weihnachten es ist höchste zeit dass die
regierung die reform zurück nimmt denn
je länger dieser konflikt dauert desto
härter wird es für sie da wieder
rauszukommen
die regierung ruft zur mäßigung auf die
züge müssen zu weihnachten fahren nicht
für die regierung oder für die
gewerkschaften sondern für die franzosen
denn die züge sind frankreichs politiker
frosch immerhin morgen wird wieder
verhandelt
george lopez hat feierabend er muss sich
gleich wieder in eine rappelvolle metro
quetschen daran sagt er müsse man sich
eben jetzt gewöhnen
vor einem jahr hatten 176 staaten den
globalen flüchtlings packt beschlossen
und sich zur hilfe verpflichtet auf dem
ersten un-gipfel danach aber spricht
außenminister maß von einer krise der
solidarität nur jedes fünfte land nehme
menschen in not auf die meisten davon
seien selber arm
deutschland ist das einzige
industrieland unter den großen
aufnahmeländer
laut der vereinten nationen sind
weltweit mehr als 70 millionen menschen
auf der flucht
die meldung erreicht uns heute früh aus
afghanistan ein fahrzeuggerät im osten
des landes auf eine mine
10 menschen sterben darunter drei kinder
gleichzeitig warnt das kinderhilfswerk
der vereinten nationen unter dem
konflikt in afghanistan leiden zunehmend
vor allem die jüngsten
in diesem jahr wurden jeden tag neun
kinder getötet oder verwundet
roland strumpf berichtet anschlag auf
ein krankenhaus im nordosten
afghanistans über mehrere stunden dauern
die gefechte
erst ein luftschlag der amerikaner der
ende den angriff der taliban tote und
verletzte und auch diesmal sind kinder
unter den opfern der islamisten
meine kleine schwester stand ganz nah
und wurde schwer verletzt
wir wissen nicht ob sie durchkommen wird
der konflikt zwischen den taliban und
der regierung wird immer gnadenloser
geführt und gerade kinder leiden
besonders auch unter den folgen
landminen die ihnen ganze gliedmaßen
abreißen
beim spielen oder auf dem weg zur schule
die opfer werden versorgt so gut es eben
geht nach jahrzehntelangen krieg ist
afghanistans boden gespickt mit
tausenden minen und blindgänger am
straßenrand sitzt module und bootsschuhe
eigentlich müsste er in der schule sein
aber ohne die umgerechnet 1 2 euro die
er verdient kämen seine eltern überhaupt
nicht über die runden
ich muss arbeiten meine mutter ist krank
wir brauchen das geld denn wir müssen
medikamente für sie kaufen zu hause
reicht es nicht einmal für einen ofen
nur eine schüssel mit glühenden kohlen
um sich im eiskalten winter notdürftig
die füße zu wärmen tod armut und
unterernährung tief haben sich die
folgen des konflikts auch in den
afghanischen alltag gegraben und machen
das land zu einem gefährlichen zu einem
tödlichen land besonders für kinder
für journalisten ist die arbeit nach
angaben von reporter ohne grenzen in
vielen ländern riskanter geworden
das zeigt die jahresbilanz der
organisation weltweit sind fast 400
journalisten in haft zwölf prozent mehr
als vor einem jahr
die meisten sitzen in china im gefängnis
49 journalisten wurden in diesem jahr
getötet sie arbeiteten in ländern wie
syrien mexiko oder afghanistan
in dem debakel um die 737 max flugzeuge
von boeing hat das unternehmen jetzt
entschieden die produktion der maschinen
wird vorläufig eingestellt
2 737 max waren abgestürzt hunderte
menschen kamen ums leben
seit mitte märz dürfen die flieger
deshalb nicht mehr abheben mehr als
4.000 bestellungen lagen zu diesem
zeitpunkt für den verkaufsschlager von
boeing vor
wohl auch deshalb wurden die maschinen
erst mal weiter gebaut und vor den
produktionshallen abgestellt dort parken
jetzt hunderte fabrik neue 737 max jenes
trams berichtet geparkt eingemottet auf
stellplätzen rund 400 flieger für 20
milliarden dollar auf halde produziert
so lange das startverbot für die 737 max
andauert darf boeing sie nicht
ausliefern
ständig so der konzern habe man die
produktionspläne überprüft jetzt zieht
die notbremse
als ergebnis dieser andauernden
überprüfungen haben wir entschieden der
lieferung gelagerter flugzeuge priorität
zu geben und die produktion der 737 ab
dem kommenden monat vorübergehend
einzustellen
grund für das startverbot zwei abstürze
in indonesien und äthiopien
346 menschen sterben die unglücke hängen
wohl mit einem stabilisierungssystem
zusammen das bei strömungsabriss die
flugzeugnase nach unten drückt mit einem
software-update wollte boeing die
flieger ende des jahres wieder an den
start bringen doch eine anhörung
vergangene woche macht klar die
us-luftfahrtbehörde geht da nicht mit
wann die 737 wieder fliegen darf das
machen wir
von abhängig ob alle
sicherheitsrelevanten punkte erfüllt
sind und vom training der piloten ein
kalender oder zeitplan spielt keine
rolle
nun also erst mal kein baum mehr des
bestverkauften flugzeugs von boeing
mitarbeiter sollen nicht entlassen
werden doch die zulieferer werden leiden
genau wie die us konjunktur insgesamt
man kann den effekt dieser entscheidung
von boeing auf die us wirtschaft kaum
überschätzen schließlich ist boeing der
größte us exporteure ungewiss die
zukunft der 737 wann immer die behörden
sie wieder fliegen lässt dann muss das
vertrauen der passagiere zurück gewonnen
werden
und gerade kamen auch diese meldung der
us senat hat sanktionen gegen firmen
beschlossen die am bau der gaspipeline
nord stream 2 beteiligt sind
die usa lehnen das projekt mit der
begründung ab die europäer machten sich
damit von russischen lieferungen
abhängig
großrazzia heute in norddeutschland
wegen des verdachts auf millionenbetrug
mit krebsmedikamenten haben mehr als 400
polizisten geschäftsräume in hamburg
schleswig holstein und niedersachsen
durchsucht
laut staatsanwaltschaft richten sich die
ermittlungen gegen ärzte apotheker und
geschäftsführer von pharmafirmen in wird
bestechung bestechlichkeit und
abrechnungsbetrug vorgeworfen der fall
jetzt legt mehr als drei jahrzehnte
zurück der deutsche student jens söring
soll in den usa die eltern seiner
freundin erstochen haben
ein us gericht verurteilte ihn zu zwei
mal lebenslanger haft er selbst beteuert
seine unschuld
30 jahre lang saß er im gefängnis heute
kehrte er nach deutschland zurück
susan von lojewski über einen fall der
immer noch fragen aufwirft
sein auftritt vor den medien er war
professionell geplant dutzende von
journalisten und kamerateams waren
gekommen um seine rückkehr nach
deutschland festzuhalten
jens söring 53 in den usa als
doppelmörder verurteilt nun ist er frei
und überglücklich ich freue mich so sehr
nach 33 jahren
sechs monaten und 25 tagen endlich
endlich hier in deutschland zu sein das
ist so toll ich bin so froh ist der
schönste tag meines lebens
der schrecklichste das war womöglich der
seiner verurteilung 1990 zweimal
lebenslänglich für den mord an den
eltern seiner damaligen freundin
elizabeth haysom sie so sagt er später
habe ihm den mord gestanden um sie vor
der todesstrafe zu retten habe er
zunächst die schuld auf sich genommen
der diplomatensohn glaubt auch er habe
immunität ein fataler irrtum
beide werden verurteilt hessen bekommt
90 jahre syring zweimal lebenslänglich
seine unterstützer glauben an seine
unschuld auch weil nie dna spuren am
tatort gefunden wurden für die us justiz
aber bleibt er schuldig dennoch hatte
die bundesregierung sich immer für ihn
eingesetzt er kommt nicht begnadigt
entschuldigt aus der haft befreit das
ist glaube ich etwas was eben noch
weiter belasten wird aber ich glaube
ganz überwiegend ist ja das element der
feiert jetzt was dominierend ist und
darüber freuen uns natürlich alle das
erste weihnachtsfest in freiheit wird
syring im europäischen süden verbringen
er will sich langsam herantasten an
einen ungewohnten alltag englische woche
in der fußball bundesliga mit einem
topspiel ein rassiges duell vorletzter
spieltag der hinrunde spitzenreiter rb
leipzig auswärts beim tabellendritten
borussia dortmund nach sieben siegen
nacheinander sind die gäste mit
reichlich selbstvertrauen angereist wohl
wissend um den aufwärtstrend des bvb es
könnte spektakulär werden weil zwei form
starke mannschaften aufeinandertreffen
mit spaß am angriffsfußball
der gegenseitige respekt ist groß
ohne unter diskussion eine sehr sehr
gute mannschaft viel power woche viele
läufe in die tiefe in angefertigt das
ist klar will das nicht außergewöhnlich
gute mannschaft mit unglaublichen tempo
mit sehr viel spielwitz in der offensive
offensiv formuliert julia nagelsmann
auch seine sportlichen ziele bis
weihnachten zwei siege in der liga und
damit die herbstmeisterschaft sollen es
sein
jetzt nach dem letzten spiel doch schon
gesagt dass wir gerne die 39 punkte
holen würden dann wäre es glaube ich
schon
ja sehr vergoldet der hinrunde das
wollen die dortmunder verhindern denn
wenn die bayern schon mal schwächeln in
der liga will der bvb die große meister
chance keinem anderen überlassen
schalkes torwart alexander niebel ist
vom dfb sportgericht für vier spiele
gesperrt worden und muss eine geldstrafe
von 12.000 euro zahlen
niebel war am sonntag seinem frankfurter
gegenspieler mini acimovic brutal mit
dem fuß gegen die brust gesprungen und
hatte rot gesehen
am tag danach entschuldigte er sich
persönlich und öffentlich beim an den
rippen verletzten serben deutschlands
beste alpine skifahrerin viktoria
rebensburg hat beim weltcup in
courchevel als vierter einen podestplatz
knapp verpasst winzige vier
hundertstelsekunden fehlten ihr im
dritten riesenslalom der saison zu rang
drei was sie ein bisschen enttäuscht
ihre team kollegin marlene schmutz
überraschte als neunter und erzielte
damit ihr bestes weltcup resultat der
tagessieg ging an die italienerin
frederica brioni die auch die disziplin
wertung anführt und am wochenende geht
es in val d'isere weiter danke christine
sonnenschein fast 20 grad das ist eher
untypisches wetter für den dezember
ob es so frühlingshaft weitergeht sagt
uns gleich katja honnefer so viele von
uns das heute journal um 21.45 mit claus
kleber und wir freuen uns morgen wieder
auf sie
punkt 7
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren heute
konnten sie auf dem satelliten film sehr
gut erkennen woher der wind weht nämlich
aus südlichen bis südwestlichen
richtungen so zogen die wolken
nordostwärts
deshalb gab es von und deswegen wurden
auch die karten rekorde eingestellt oder
sogar gebracht hat hamburg neuwiedenthal
meldete uns fast 14 grad und bad
kohlgrub am alpenrand über 18 grad so
warm war es dort noch nie mitte dezember
die 19 grad
die gelten für rosenheim da war es auch
schon mal wärmer
jetzt aber wird erst mal kühler am
vierten advent also am sonntag liegen
die höchsttemperaturen nur noch zwischen
4 grad am alpenrand und 10 grad am
oberrhein und damit ist der sonntag nur
unwesentlich wärmer als unsere nacht
heute denn die tiefsttemperaturen liegen
zwischen 9 und 0 grad im nordwesten wird
es heute nacht regnet
im südosten ist es dagegen häufig klar
oder nur locker bewölkt und morgen sind
die meisten regenwolken aus deutschland
abgezogen aber zwischen dem spreewald
und dem saarland ist es stärker bewölkt
da kann es auch mal tröpfeln und es ist
längst nicht mehr so warm wie heute mit
temperaturen von acht bis 15 grad
der donnerstag wird nämlich und danach
gibt es wieder regen schönen abend noch